What do you think is the best type of testing to have done
in order to help to determine what diet will likely work
for a person?
Well, this is kind of a loaded question.
You know, when we see a person that has a diagnosis of cancer,
we do testing our cheek swab testing
to find out what we think is feeding the cancer
that take off, take those things out of a person's diet.
So cancer can be fed through different fuel sources.
It can be fed through different metabolic processes.
And you have to often change the diet
because it can bite a fuel source.
I don't know if this person is asking about cancer or not.
So let's shift a little bit.
So if I don't have cancer, what kind of diet should I be doing?
Should I be doing a caramor diet?
Should I be doing a keto diet?
There's tons of different fan diets out there.
What's a good one to be on?
Well, what's a good one to be on is one that is right for your body.
How do I know what's right for my body?
Well, to test your gut and see what you are not reacting to.
So if a part has health issues, you want to at least be
one of the initial components of an evaluation
is to look at a person's gut because you aren't just
what you eat, you are what you absorb, you are what you retain,
you are what you don't detoxify.
And we are exposed to so many things that damage our gut.
And once our gut is damaged, then we can develop antibodies
to foods that are actually good, that are healthy foods.
But if we have antibodies to that healthy food,
every time we eat that healthy food,
we're causing more inflammation and more damage to our gut.
So how do I know that without testing for it?
So running some labs is really the way to go
when you're looking at what is the best diet for me.
Here's an example.
Well, I'm going to go on a caramor diet because I've
heard about this person who had an autoimmune disease.
They went on a caramor diet, they basically really
called everything down and quote-unquote cured their problem.
Well, the truth is that can be bad for some people.
If you ran an antibody test and you have antibodies to meats
and you're eating meat, then you have antibodies to,
you're not going to call them things down
and it's not going to work for you.
That person that it worked for obviously
didn't have antibodies to meet.
Maybe antibodies don't whole bunch of things, but not meet.
At least the meat he was choosing,
he or she was choosing to eat and they ate those meats.
And then they weren't eating the things
that they had antibodies against.
And that called the inflammation down
and they were able to do other things to heal their gut
so that those antibodies to those other foods
may be slowly dissipated because antibodies to foods
for the most part will dissipate over time.
And they were able to go on a back to a fairly normal diet
and their problem was helped very much.
So the way you'd find out what diet is best for you
is to run some tests.
So there's different lab tests that you can run.
I would start with like Syrex Array 2
to see the level of damage of the gut wall first.
And if that exists, depending on the person's symptoms,
I would make clinical decisions from that.
So how I make clinical decisions
for the discussion with the person,
get a fairly good health history.
No going on, no going on.
No going on.
Those goals are where we want to move from there.
That's what we call case review.
So if you want to do a case review with me over the phone,
you could do so.
You could find out information.
You could schedule it yourself on coddersclinic.com.
So that's what I thought about that.
You want to test as many things as you can
when you're trying to make clinical decisions.
You want to try to base it as much on objective
findings as you possibly can.